what is a classical liberal it sounds
like someone who's a liberal but perhaps
a bit fancier may be sporting a top hat
a twirly mustache and a monocle tea time
well that might be true in some specific
cases there's a lot more to it than that
and I bet I can convince you that
there's a little classical liberal in
you too in about two minutes classical
liberalism is the idea that individual
freedom and limited government are the
best way for humans to form a free
society the classical liberal tradition
was born from great thinkers such as
John Locke Adam Smith John Stuart Mill
and Thomas Jefferson while they all
tinkered in their own way with the ideas
of classical liberalism the core belief
that the individual should always be
considered above the gloom always remain
constant Thomas Jefferson even threw in
the pursuit of happiness in the
Declaration of Independence to drive
home the point that your happiness
wasn't the government's to give but
rather yours to take
putting the individual above the group
not only empowers you to live your life
as you see fit but it also neutralizes
the forces of racism and bigotry which
judge people not on their individuality
but on their immutable characteristics
be a color of skin gender or sexuality
these days liberalism has been confused
with leftism or progressivism which
actually has nothing to do
with classical liberalism sadly the left
is no longer liberal at all for his
created in individualism for
collectivism thus placing us in an
oppression Olympics where victimhood
is virtue this post-modernism this
cultural Marxism or whatever you want to
call it can only destroy it cannot
create if he bucked the trend and dare
succeed as a member of one of these
supposed oppressed minorities you must
be tossed aside because your success is
confirmation of the failure of this
worldview
this is what the left is offering and
that's not classically liberal it's
radically a liberal so it doesn't matter
if you're a liberal a conservative a
libertarian or an independent it doesn't
matter if you're a Christian or an
atheist a man or a woman or black or
white what matters is whether you wish
to live as a free person in a free
society based on your own ideas and
actions I suspect that you do and if I'm
right there's already a little classical
liberal in you right now
[Music]
[Music]